next question how does the close of probation
and noah's time inform the close of probation
at the end of time well that's fine i'll
look at that in luke 17 from verse 26
and as it was in the days of noah so shall it be
also in the days of this coming of the son of man
they d they drank they married wives they were
given in marriage until the day that noah entered
into the ark and the flood came and took them
away likewise also as it was in the days of law
they drank they bought their soul they planted
the building but the same day a lot went out of
sodom it rained fire and brimstone from god out of
heaven and destroy them and so they had a period
of probation in the days of noah they had one of
the days of love because lot went out to preach
to talk to his sons-in-law and perhaps to others
they did not listen god always gives people an
opportunity some time to do what is right now
on the individual level probation varies god
may give me 10 years he may give you 10 000. it
depends on the person's individual circumstances
but in the days of noah there was a probationary
period in the days of lot there was also one
the period for noah is mentioned as 120 years
it is not mentioned for lot but we know that
lot as an agent of god preached and called upon
his sons-in-law and whoever else would listen
to come out of that city and they did and so god
sends warnings he gives a certain amount of time
and then he says that's it and he cuts you off
in love because he realizes nothing he does
will change your mind you've come to the place
where you're so set in error nothing will change
your mind or you've come to the place where you're
so set in truth nothing the devil does can turn
you from christ one of those two conditions
a person arrives at and that probation closes
so the closest probation is not a frightening
thing unless it closes and you are outside of god
if it closes when you're in god is the greatest
news you can find because then you cannot be lost
you understand me if you read revelation
14 well let me offer prayer again father
as i continue to speak give me wisdom i pray in
jesus name amen in revelation 14 there are two
harvests both harvests are ripe in other words
it's time to put in the sickle for the harvest
is right joel chapter 3 verse 13 put you in the
sickle for the harvest is right and so that's
the pudding of the sickle means probation
has closed i'm coming to reach the harvest
but there are two harvests in revelation 14 the
harvest of the lost and the harvest of the same
the only thing similar about them is both harvests
are ripe one harvest is right against god the
other is right for god and so when jesus declares
he that is unjust let him be unjust revelation 22
11 what that statement means some people have
reached have come to the close of the probation
their side of god others they are within god so
that declaration of the clause of probation means
summer out some are in when god closed the door of
the ark genesis 7 verse 16 some were out some were
in and the door was not open to letting those
who were out because they had been given enough
time and so we study noah's time lots time so we
can understand how we ought to live in this time
because jesus said that's the way it will be in
his days when he comes which are these last days
and we studied lots time and those times that we
put ourselves in the right position regarding god
let me say again god is eternal but his
patience is limited because he hates sin
amen amen god hates sin but you know i
really appreciate the fact that god gives us
time to make a decision for him right that he's
not a god of coercion which is why he gives us a
period of probation now there's something i would
like to share on noah's time as i was reading uh
you know about the time of probation
that god gave to noah those 120 years
here's what ellen white says in manuscript 65
the year 1906 which speaks about the individual
probationary time that god has given us she sees
some of the carpenters he that is noah employed
in building the ark believed the message but died
before the flood right others of noah's converts
backslid many of the believing ones kept the
faith and died triumphant now that's manuscript
35 the year 1906. the the fact of the matter is
or the the general theme that we have to glean is
as he said elder steve where will we be
when our probation closes that's right
will we be among the believing or will
we be among the backsliding that's right
you